[Musique]
je vous laisse deviner où on est on est
à la presse française des samsung galaxy
s 10 s10 plus est 10e
alors aujourd'hui trois questions qui tu
es qu'est ce qu'il fait et qu'est ce
t'en penses tu que tu adores bas apràs
de w dit que point fr yes we camp qu'est
ce que tu penses toi de la nouvelle
gamme s 10 bah j'aime beaucoup l'écran
j'aime beaucoup l'appareil photo donc
j'ai hâte de jouer avec ça donne ok
quelqu'un qui te tue coiffure est le
plus elles se disent s10 plus c'est la
n10 performance là celui à 1600 euros et
qui nico du blog un autre blog.com
ok cool alors qu'est ce que tu en penses
toi de cs 10 nous cette année
j'avance c'est pas mal après je
comprends pas trop la série avec le
petit le plus petit là qu'ils ont fait
l'essentiel de walden a exactement après
je suis très fan toujours comme d'hab du
grand format donc le disque us
sinon niveau futur j'aime beaucoup le
capteur d'empreinte avec écran et en mai
et en frontal de négoce ou l'écran ça
seigneur parce que enfin typiquement
mots je suis le mec qui cause de mon
téléphone est sur la table mais jamais à
faire des petits tchèque enfin unis
verrouillé sans avoir à lever ou de
matériel ok donc ça plutôt cool loi sa
lutte et qui gérait muni du blog
monsieur escarpins comme nef
alors tu en penses quoi 10 mois de
hausse et va écoute trois très bons
produits après moi je suis plus attiré
vers le s10 soulève discus hockey voilà
le sens elle matière moi j'aime beaucoup
la stabilisation qu'ils ont fait montre
les accusations de l'image le lecteur
d'empreintes même canton même quand on
l'a on vient de transpirer si on fait du
sport ou autre c'est parfait je serai
doublement on n'est pas emmerdé par ça
et sinon temps globalement très bon
produit une bonne qualité d'écran et
plutôt une gamme très prometteuse encore
2,10 sa lutte et qui salut je m'appelle
mise aux arrêts du blog comics tête ok
alors qu'est ce que t'en penses quoi de
ses smartphones cette année à moi j'aime
bien les nouveaux smartphones mais je
suis beaucoup plus attirés vers le s10
donc l'es10 plus c'est peut-être un peu
trop grand pour mes petites mains et
l'essentiel c'est pas forcément dans ma
gamme ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est
l'appareil photo je suis vraiment
intéressé par toutes les options que ça
offre d'accord le madelinot hésiter
enfin on va ce communiste et j'ai envie
de comparer ça à un pixel fois par
exemple les 3 capteurs il faut que je m
ça forcément en pratique parce que je
veux voir si ça sert de plus en plus
comparé comme toujours un pixel est
forcément avoir un capteur des crampes
un capteur d'empreintes digitales sous
l'écran c'est toujours meilleur
si tu fais quoi nous sommes encore en
période
ok je vais d'alençon de plus je consulte
mes vidéos de danse
j'ai aussi un jeu construit mais
l'avancé du coup le smartphone c'est
bien mais se disent franchement elle est
super
il est vraiment au top j'ai pas vraiment
meilleur téléphone
jusque là les quelques photos vidéos
l'est les hawks au kick ass est juste
énorme sa lutte et qui tu fais quoi
hello je l'appelle clémentine influence
ouais tu peux en sauce sur quoique
l'équipe de tutoriaux tué sur instagram
quoi ces pathogènes clémence m
ok cool qu'est ce que tu en penses de
serrer le jeu tu avances de cette gamme
de sd eibar j'aime beaucoup mais je suis
une fan de samsung de base j'ai eu que
ça dans ma vie
d'accord donc là j'avais hâte de
découvrir jeu très très très très très
satisfait d'accord et qu'est ce qui te
plaît le plus tout ce qui est photo ou
vidéo
ouais comme beaucoup beaucoup de gens je
pense donc je trouve que c'est très
pratique qu'ils ont bien bien bossé
là-dessus et sylvain enfin mois par
rapport à mon métier déjà ça va beaucoup
me servir et je pense que beaucoup de
gens se servent principalement de ça sur
leur téléphone ok est-ce que tu as
regardé harry potter la dernière fois à
londres
parce que s'il vous souvenez pas là
jamais vu harry potter c'est pas normal
d'y star wars
elle a pas de star wars jusqu'à whaou
regardez lequel harry potter bat le
premier et henri stoll qu à la fin il me
dit palmer fait d'accord pour garder le
way sa lutte et qui tu sais quoi bonjour
m'appelle guy je fais quoi faire
raccourcir médias influenceurs outtakes
bd jeux vidéo jeux de société puisque tu
veux vaincre top
pourquoi de fesdis hier couple et autres
écoutent beaucoup trouvent le plus les
dix plus très clairement
visuellement la
la caméra frontale ultra bien placé
ultra bien agencé on a pu tester la
comparaison avec le s9 plus de l'an
dernier niveau luminosité nocturne est
clairement un gap
contre dans les démonstrations c'était
[Musique]
vraiment occasion une boite noir profond
donc il y avait quasiment qu'une mère
vous voyez très bien on
on a pu voir des nouvelles améliorations
au niveau de la photographie et comptera
grand temps où le grand angle l'angle
simple pas mal jihad incorporé donc
ouais c'est vrai
la nouvelle vague des smartphones
plein d d'intelligence artificielle bush
c'est en photographie tout ce qu'on leur
demande c'est trois grands axes liés à
la photo la batterie le grand écran
incurvé
c'est vraiment la nouvelle grande vague
avec le 3xl le may d'impôt le système
tout ça et des chiens exactement sa
lutte et qui tu fais quoi salut je suis
elisabeth et je suis la cofondatrice
d-box com
yes qu'est ce que tu en penses tu de
cette gamme est vif écoute moi je suis
une grande fan de samsung donc déjà je
pars avec un atout ou un handicap sein
des rangs pour qui je trouve qu'il est
très bien il est très léger ils ont bien
géré notamment la petite la petite bulle
comme ils appellent maintenant ça
s'appelle plus un dépôt d'une motion
tout ça ça s'appelle pur un trou ça
s'appelle une bulle
donc je trouve que c'est plutôt joli il
est esthétique mois encore une fois je
suis pas dans la technique donc je me
base sur des choses que je vois que je
sens etc
et je trouve qu'il est
il est à la fois ergonomique de ce que
j'ai pu tester
esthétique et apparemment performant
donc voilà rawa avoir contesté nous on
l'a déjà on va le tester jusqu'au
tréfonds et puis on a aussi fait une
petite vidéo avec toutes les
fonctionnalités sur la chaîne i d'ebooks
je suis un peu de pub et puis
et puis je pense que c'est un bon
produit quoi c'est du samsung donc
donc voilà et je suis très fidèle
c'est beau bah ouais merci et que c'est
très beau ils ont ma parole un peu
l'histoire de la gare la gamme galaxy
ace alors crédit vous avez regardez moi
ce vieux truc galaxy s ce à cette époque
écran super amoled en en 2010 galaxy s2
galaxy s3 premier écran hd bienvenue
galaxy s 4 premières écran full hd
galaxy s cinq galaxies s6 s6 edge alors
là on à l'écran edge et on est en q1 hd
galaxy s est et à cet âge le 8,8 plus
l'écran infiniti 9,9 plus si on arrive
ici avec trois smartphones qui arrivent
d'un coup le e le 10 et le plus écran
infiniti 93 % de surfaces occupées
c'est la première fois que je vois ça et
je suis extrêmement 3 n'apparaissent pas
faire le point sur toi pour te voyais je
suis très fier de tout les infographies
qu'il y en a un je prends vraiment que
tu as fait un excellent travail avec
tant qu'on vient de toutes ces
infographies il y en a dix contrats
parce que moi désintégrer du tiens moi
tu as passé combien d'heures à faire ça
mais j'étais travail d'équipé gabon bel
événement jean vitus havas en quoi ça
vous écoute très bon accueil
ouais mais très content de tout ce qu'il
est les petits fours sont très bons oui
je trouvais très important alors leur et
celle qui est présentement c'est
toujours triste c'est que babu vous
pouvez pas le savoir mais nous on se
régale n'est ce pas vous voulez vraiment
très très bon très bon feeds ah oui
c'est ça ça va du pad à la fois qu'on
s'interdise keaton d'un nouvel j'adore
c'est le mec hyper lourd il à me [ __ ]
la paix tu m'as vu tu m'as pas parler
aujourd'hui
alors je vais en parler de moi le truc
un peu cool et +31 qu'est ce que je peux
dire de cool je suis pas très drôle
avant donc le site et hip hop funk et
non les personnes que barbara toujours
pas vu harry potter est là et tu sais
quoi elle à pabu star wars the game of
thrones cv starr mais oui quoi me disais
alors du coup un mois dans les spéciales
instagram en fait exactement on va voir
une nouveauté sur l'appareil photo qui
est un mode instagram directement dans
l'application photos
parce que l'on peut publier directement
sans ta g sur les autres smartphones en
pouvait en fait on avait une perte de
qualité notamment les vidéos sur les
story là on va pouvoir en fait partager
directement depuis la petite photo
hockey a bien un mode dédié c'est pas le
bois d'instagram ses photos et ses
vidéos directement dans l'appli des
comores et en images comment il
fonctionne
l'idée c'est qu'on a pas de pire qu'une
dit exactement on va pouvoir du coup
filmé depuis son capteur principal avec
le s10 et publier ses contenus sur
instagram sans perte de qualité
ok génial qui commence à marcher avant
en fait alors en fait avant sur
l'évaluation précédente notamment sur
dué suite du spf reprenait une photo
notamment et qu'on la mettait en story
par ta g venait en fait légèrement
dégradé la qualité de l'image
sa qualité négative et on se retrouve
avec une photo qui était moins bonne
qualité
voilà donc pour aujourd'hui sujet pris
sur le vif
on se rencontre on se présente on dit ce
qu'on fait on parle hop je me mets bien
comme il faut on parle du smartphone et
l'idée c'est vraiment le proposant un
sujet un peu à part de pas vous dire
forcément moi ce que j'en pense
parce que ces galaxies et se dit çà se
disent plus s10e occupe vraiment là que
tu en ce moment on en reparle passé la
teste qui arrive d'ici quelques jours la
chanterelle tester le s10 plus drôle est
10e qui va suivre ce que je vous propose
déjà passé de vous abonner comme ça vous
saurez tout et puis je trouve ça assez
intéressant d'aller à la rencontre
d'autres blogueurs influents soeur qui
peuvent vous donner un avis différent et
voir un peu les les points qui
ressortent c'est intéressant de pouvoir
voir un peu les quels sont les points
qui retiennent le plus l'attention on en
reparle dans quelques jours comme ça
vous saurez tout en tout cas tout ce que
moi j'en pense sur ce s 10 plus embrasse
à de maintien